what's up fool what's up fool uh-huh
she's gonna have to say yeah man might
have to say yeah man
corrosion night here so you just say
yeah man I have to act like Rodrigo just
say yeah man all right good we'll talk
about a little bit you know about what
happened this weekend and we'll bring in
Brian Scholl or hope or more his stuff
West where he's from and other ladies
All Right see you fool what some fool
man was some fool right here man with um
my co-host
um Fred Stoller I have to act like
Rodrigo you say yeah man yeah man that's
a nice cream no he is the human oh but
but like I'll do something like yeah he
goes how you doing I'm all right ha ha
yeah I said how he laughs I don't know
how about you laughs green it's like
screaming in your ear uh inch away from
it then once I would do the show and
there was a guy laughing like that all
my jokes and then when they had Lana
went up and he wasn't laughing and I
gather was laughing at the joke sitting
next to me how come you're not laughing
at me bro what are you his [ __ ] laugh
track or what you got you got baby you
got you got it out yeah marry some vegan
donors you want one you scare that
that's not sound good okay this is vegan
with anything they always go it's just
like chocolate no it's nice that I know
cacao so what's up for my jogo weekend
and we reporting I'm sayin man I'm
saving it yeah we're recording I just
want to say no I'm be Arizona is the
place to be if he just got over a food
poisoning it's just bars and bar I mean
Rose streets of shitty bar food like
fried whatever the hell sticks and the
only thing I would do is go to PJ Chang
so soup and it's it's a college town
with no books
just just people with guns and so
otherwise but you made it good somehow
the hostess trip bored but we didn't go
to them huh I didn't see anything it was
oh I've been here before when I saw some
crazy stuff but not this time man but
yeah my there's a lot deep fried food if
you like deep fried food if I pickles
deep fried slows explain Arizona to me
like why would is there mountains is
there anything picturesque as my mother
would say what is the thing about it
that would make someone want to live
there all sides getting away from Mexico
and probably could they have um free
dental for everybody something now there
were nice crowds area oh yeah your
crowds the only trouble we had was one
guy Hey look into the green room yeah
I'm already in first older he comes in
he's looks like a Mexican Dahmer a
Mexican Andy Kindler that makes any
sense sits next to me puts his arm
around yo yo man hey and and and I know
and I go oh I guess they love any random
comic in the green room which they ended
up doing but they weren't so bad my last
show I was so tired and and then that we
had to share the green room then there
was a these guys would scream out
because I like it's acting and running
sighs yo Seinfeld yo sign there so then
in my last show I'm resting before I
have to do the pictures with Felipe and
this guy's banging on it they hear
something coming out severe we need
[ __ ] I've heard he sounded like a
Pacino or something yeah or Christopher
Walken you know yo we got guns in here
in Arizona and so it was um I was target
those funny where they go just knock ha
ha I knew you were in the green room
window nothing pictures [ __ ] surf out
they must have an invisible sign go
bother Fred and bang on the door just
walk in least that guy knocked down odd
like the 18th dat mo what do they call
the tobacco firearm yeah man like Koresh
I thought it's gonna kill it's a pretty
good foot
actually found out of that chain
restaurant Ike's it's a San Francisco
restaurant called ice and I ate there it
was pretty good my that's only place the
only restaurant or you could say you
know what um can you i jalapeno poppers
and and and onion rings to my sandwich
and I'll put it in there I I like just
bland chicken I mean but Dada I don't I
don't mean I just mean like I don't mean
it's shitty like in a hospital my
favorite color is clear yeah
I just mean safe kind of chicken but
good you know they mean I don't mean
just like a cafeteria chicken just
something kind of American ish food and
and I didn't find that but I thought my
mother a random Mother's Day card at CVS
I do a thing where I take the first one
off the first one I see I can't put any
effort into this and and it's and it was
seven bucks but I was ready at the
counter it's one of things where you
open it up Bing Bing Bing
jackpot noises cuz you won the I won the
jackpot when I got you as a mom which is
not true yeah cuz I go I was too late I
scanned it I had I read he was gonna get
it in three days late but it's it makes
all these bells like the jackpot went
through one time I was so
passive-aggressive when I lived in New
York I visited her and for Mother's Day
I got Apple do you remember his plaques
I got one that said get well soon
and she didn't even go ye I'm not sick
but you go so thank you and she put on a
shelf like I'm [ __ ] so so my Arizona
hahahaha so she just said oh she went
and she always goes oh chuckling oh
really she goes oh I got your card it
was it was cute she doesn't go you
really think you won the jackpot with me
you know I won the jackpot for putting a
bullet in my head but otherwise
otherwise it was good and Rodrigo he's a
good guy but he loves to scream when he
laughs yeah I mean and pathetic idiots
and and I had like like I said stomach
poisoning and I was true
to have like Latin noises so I tried to
do say things so he wouldn't laugh and
scream in my ear
but that only backfired how you do it
what do you have and I'm just gonna have
an apple Fred's having an apple ah you
know I'm talking about the time I met
him I didn't know what a sweet sweet guy
he is and he was laughing like those
gangsters you know they mean and in
Goodfellas when they you know chopping
someone's head off ha ha this head came
off yeah but he's he's the sweetest and
I I tell you I some people asked me to
do my candy Manny voice for their kids
so and the iPhones is very fulfilling so
no I like it if you you know when you
you know it makes a kid feel good like I
did this cartoon and three-year-olds and
sometimes on the iPhone go hi I'm here
I'm scared I'm in Phoenix they have guns
all those guys did that for that guy
though that gave us dabs oh you did some
dad's for the forever knew what tabs
were and let me tell you it was like
doing five edibles it was it's like
crack they take out this torch and and
I'm and I'm pretty new to pot just a
year and I did it and all of a sudden
I'm backstage in the green room with
Rodrigo screaming laughing at everything
and they're replaying the Clipper game
and I'm going okay I gotta get to the
safety of my room but I was afraid to go
out there I just had to find the driver
and I was afraid like that the Seinfeld
Latinos would tackle me on the way out
seven and on the phone and and Rodrigo
is convinced someone's the 19 year old
really good-looking driver we had
gorgeous he looks like the guy in which
tickle did Boardwalk Empire he's saying
oh no you just hang out at the bar you
get laid you know at the end so that's
for the 19 year old stud remember that
guy that for me and Rodrigo so Rodrigo
right he was sitting there go
hanging out with a fools wife man and so
I just had to get I just had a hope that
my passkey worked those past Keys
sometimes you either have to go to
bathroom so bad and you're up there and
because it wasn't in your credit card
it's not opening or you got to go back
down and oh man
so I just I just hid in my room
it's really weird cuz you know with
edibles if I'm tripping and blitzed I
I'm in the safety of my apartment but
I'm in a hotel room I feel like Marion
Barry you know they mean doing crack in
a hotel and I'm there going my only
paranoia was okay first I put that
Seinfeld guy on Instagram yo Seinfeld
man we got guns in Arizona you're lucky
you are like a video of her and then I
got scared my paranoia was that he'd see
it go you [ __ ] you made fun of me so so
I took it down and then I wish I my only
thing my concern was oh here's that's
the key
my only concern was I knew would wear
off but I didn't know how long so I knew
I'd get arrested if I was like that
staggering at the airport and you
propping me up so I said as long as this
I go at worst-case scenario I'll pay
with my own money and not the night at
the hotel and my own airfare just to
chill it off but it worked out well
though you're safe man oh man but thank
you for Philippe thank you for we have a
Debra not ready well I'm glad I had the
experience I don't know if I'd do it
again all right would you do - oh you
did do it again first he was doing more
right there
I don't get it what's up fool what's up
full flip Esparza right here first order
filling everyone against today man
a guy that I met at the Laugh Factory
very funny guy and this guy's been on a
lot of things that I've seen first of
all my favorite cartoon life and tell
it's him
and I'm who very funny guy my Brasco
Laura were so full all the way from the
East Coast baby sort of hi man thanks
for having me on
Merry Christmas yeah man hallelujah so
Deb's just a hash oil right there's hats
on that there was a guy I was
Lyn's Washington there was an MC oh yeah
you were there right and all the guys
that set him up in each city that big
the big giant guy with the Mohawk comes
the aroma oh oh that guy that guy he
came into the room and then he gave me a
bunch of dabs and then my opener got
panicked and locked himself in the room
and then all these cats yeah yeah then
all these kids are walking by and these
there were kids and I see is this big
guy with a mohawk and I want to talk to
him and I just go inside because I don't
really want to talk to kids I'm on the
road you know what I mean I'm also
apparently on something called dabs and
I'd like to not talk to a group of kids
sitting the guy with the Mohawk comes in
he goes are you jealous of my hair and I
go wow he's like well you walked away
you will the kids came up to me I was
like no dude no was a Josie here guys I
got my drugs and I'd like to not talk to
children that's kind of what that was
his first guest that I was jealous how
long his dad's been around and it wasn't
called it was called hash oil when I did
it now there's a name now why do you
need a blowtorch yeah you gotta heat up
the you gotta heat up the bowl so it
gets hot then you get the long stem and
you know to hold the oil and you dab it
some guy invented this and it just went
around yeah
some think it might have a negative
having me on for being here man a lot of
things besides the cartoon tell us man I
know okay I know you liked the cartoon a
lot I always wanted to love till I read
for the part of Horatio Sanz he got the
part get the part yet yeah during the
third season they sawed up everybody was
doing through celebrities in there we
got difficult Super Dave Osborne called
me a fat turd a real knife no no and
there's a scene right it was sort of
like real life there's a scene where I'm
with selling hot dogs or falafels I
think and then the guy plays Steve's
that the guy who plays Tim's diva
standing there and then Super Dave
Osborne supposed to talk for a while and
they wanted me to go in there so that
super they
my husband had a conversation to start
off from you know I mean but I had no
lines in his scene I'm just a hot dog
better but he doesn't know that so he
thinks he's trying to improv with
everybody she goes who's this fat turd
thinking I'll say something I'm a I'm a
[ __ ] falafel vendor so why would I
talk to him you know I mean we had he
called me fat turd and I just had to
take him and then when he left unless
one fat turd and everybody start
laughing because I could tell it was
bothering me but in say a [ __ ] word
because he's Super Dave Osborne but it
wasn't very nice but yet at the same
time he's trying to avow me but the
cartoon now they're supposed to know I'm
fat Felipe I know right I mean like you
just went after the real thing that
pissed me off
what's that no I know I never played fat
cartoon characters just fat real-life
characters just hairy characters hairy
characters that were you good that's
what I can know I get if I don't I read
forever I don't get him I isn't aware
the guy who's on Finding Bigfoot it
looks a lot like Bigfoot himself like
he's looking for himself the whole time
he's just a big fat hairy guy come we
can't find Bigfoot we're looking for
because you're [ __ ] Bigfoot man
anyway thanks for every I'll take care
guys so what's off we for Brooklyn New
York I was born in Brooklyn Brooklyn
from there where I will party from
Sheepshead Bay from Bay Ridge then
Bensonhurst I work one Brooklyn Avenue
him ocean is where yeah that's awesome
what's the three broken so big there was
a slight Bay Parkway or something and I
was a Goodyear man for one day on a
bicycle and it was conscious one day and
it was in a kosher neighborhood and the
kids were just look at me were yarmulkes
like we can't have this they would look
at me you're probably much younger than
me but there was EJ Corvettes and that's
where I was to get records by the
Verrazano Bridge that's where I was born
by the verse now now now now it's a yeah
big flea market I think but no wow yeah
first of all I'm a big fan of both you
guys we're big fans I have a fan just
for a very long time if anyone says
watching that TV year old college
graduate just make me laugh you go I
want to finish college my mother was
like we just finished college why
because then you could say you were a
college graduate like I can't say it now
I'm a college good guy
I'm a college girl a gag away laughs
along to more credits I almost had it
yeah it was great joke
sure so shirts like that oh wow sell
shirts that's it that's not a better
color good guy good guy
it's not a bad idea where'd you live
after Brooklyn Queens in Manhattan that
I moved here in 2001 I do a TV show we
provision yeah it was called three
sisters it was on before Frazier and
then the day we premiered I think a wait
a minute uh well I always had a crush on
vicki lewis yeah big you lose I like
redheads yeah she was she still talk to
her she's awesome yeah yeah she was the
redhead on Newsradio
yeah and we premiered and then 9/11
happened and everybody stopped watching
TV for like a year that was fun and then
stuff good stuff disappeared during a 99
man yeah a lot of great movies like
things are doing dem doin your dad right
I saw that in the fear why did that Rose
appear because of 9/11 because Beauty
lips are moving huh I think that was
before 9/11 I maybe there was no
bleeding there I don't know Romeo's
bling there's a lot of best of happening
9/11 besides all the people time yeah
yeah the worst is that now I have to
call I have to call cities and find
marijuana before I get on the plane
instead I just flying with it like I
used to you don't flow there no more no
lie with what any marijuana I'm scared
okay I haven't flown with it a long time
flew to Seattle last time I flew in I
used to put it in tin foil and then tin
foil but it'll go off Ali oh it wasn't
him Flo with something else I'm thinking
though Thank You saran wrap and then I
tape it to that pouch above your your
dick you know if you're fat you got a
little pouch Rafi may style right not
that big not not a huge pouch but I had
like a decent size normal person sized
pouch with a little extra padding I'm
always paranoid man like I got the face
of someone's gonna bring in something
anyway do he do look like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah we got teased because
coming home they said you could go in
the line we don't have to take your
shoes off then we're gonna take our
shoes off so I was so psyched then I
take my shoes off yeah recheck it
there's a pre-check
I mean why don't we check exists I know
everybody huh well I don't stand why
what'll I tell the Pratt hoping they get
lucky hoping they're guessing like yeah
you guys will protect you as long as you
pay $100 yeah willow said the pre check
is for more money you don't have to
shoes that's kind of defeats the whole
purpose of checking the terrorists
they're going all right let's blow up
the plane with our shoes although only
if we had another $100 damn it now we
can't blow it up with our shoes though
saying it's yeah it's rude does it make
any sense
a lot of this logic isn't it prejudice
because sometimes you pay more money for
more space now and well that's a big
fight you could you could bring a bomb
on the plane if you pay $100 I think we
could pass that I hate flying
uh me too me yeah Ares everywhere no
Arizona at least with a short flight but
it's you guys flew yeah I'm driving I'm
in Scottsdale and this weekend and I'm
I'm [ __ ] driving and I'll tell you
what's really you were talking about
what's good about Arizona here's one
thing I don't understand why they don't
seem to follow the same rules as
everybody else in regards to time zones
yes all of a sudden they'll be like you
think you have an hour to get to the
show and like yeah we we just don't do
that here what do you mean don't do that
what he took oh they just don't stop
they don't have a time zone thing what
do you they don't change their time yep
little daylight saving the whole world
we were there at a different time I got
confused
no no see this time it's not there it
didn't change because we changed they're
the same again they're the same as us
because we changed but one next time we
change they'll be different than like
next time we go there and we leave there
one or we get there it'll still be too I
said they're in the same time zone but
they don't do daylight save that and
that that kind of blows my mind that
they refuse to accept that something is
the time which you think is nature but I
guess it's not and it's therefore I'm
gonna deal with it with the government
nothing ma'am we'll give you guys marcha
luther king birthday and Cesar Chavez a
holiday playing I'm [ __ ] with it
time zone okay I didn't know that well
thanks for having me on
what's up fool hi do you got everybody
for are you having everybody but Harris
what's so cool my mom - what's up fool
yeah parents-in-law you call them fools
yeah
they don't do that I don't I don't tell
him I was so foolish II don't know
what's up man you were on stacked with
Pamela - the shoulders Pam and I'm gold
Ilan gold two years Christopher Lloyd
was also speaking of things to do with
everyone you're dead he wasn't that I
worked with him for two years that was
that night television show man saw
something I don't know what's it like do
you children like how act somebody
accompanies all active [ __ ]
he'll get rub off I'll get more lines no
but some people are like that and then I
was like a son of this man for like
there were so many comedians on that
show fighting for time train will pass
though the broom it was in the world for
rules but he's worth the painting you
know next to uh Bill Doyle throw me I
don't marry he was turning over outs and
again Laurel I don't know some shows are
like very uh well I wrote the book right
a guest star life hadn't have been a
regular but some of them they're cool to
the guest star guys and some of them not
I'm not in yeah so I was the Raymond
when you played Raymond's uh cousin -
that was a good part thank you alright
that was a cool show except um I've
talked about this so just repeating
myself but no do you feel left out is
the guest star cuz they're talking about
what they're gonna wear the yeah me say
new houses yeah yo I'm only making three
hunt and Brad Garrett was [ __ ] and he's
only making 300,000 an episode race
making two and I'm they're making
whatever 4,000 which is cool and right
in front of you and they're giving out
plasma TVs for a everyone welcome back
us is in your pocket you know and so
some of them some of them you feel part
of it but that was a big big hit but
you're walking on eggshells with that
one that
we self-important so some of the what
once I had the most fun on no one
watched but but it was a loose
atmosphere III as when I was a regular
on things I I was a great life and then
to go from regular things to my getting
did to go to back to what this thing
will go back to recurring z' and guest
roles it's a very different difficult
transition it's like food I you said I
used to be able to say anything I wanted
to on the set now I can't yes you know
my book it's called maybe we'll have you
back I'll check that out
and I would talk about now and they
didn't and about ever when you're a
guest
you can't flub a line and crack up yeah
you ever see the gag reel where they
crack up and high-fiving there was a
guest or Brian no no I laughed on when I
was on Dexter I left oh you are Dexter I
think I was I could try to take this
joke you do what the Dexter uh season
two the episode where they catch Doakes
and they lock him in a cage where he
locks me yeah yeah yeah I am an FBI
agent who takes over his lab so I have
like four scenes with Dexter where I'm
like hey give it your computer and then
I key kicked me I kick him out of the
room because he's annoying me purposely
and then at the end I'm like hey we were
going after the black guy he's like
great watch the centrifuge for 24 hours
so where's Dexter cool guy to work with
yeah it was the first when he's there
the first week he was very much in
character uh-huh and he was like he
looked like he was he looked at you like
he was thinking about dissect oh yeah
yeah and then like at the end of the
week he was all relaxing in a better
mood and he was very nice he's going
through can't write in a divorce and I
will say this I was eating lunch on this
on the shooting something else there
like a month later and he walked by
recognized me and wave that came over
and talked to me that's pretty cool no
there's some really cool down-to-earth
people and there's some that so shows
were a lot of fun Grey's Anatomy they
were tremendous really nice to me they
were all happy and successful but not
like giving each other TVs and going the
Emmys but they were just happy yeah and
then some shows where things aren't
going good like the show you mentioned
it's a little tense
well also when you get when you work
with people that like you said Grey's
Anatomy that have like I knew Patrick
Dempsey and he was so happy later in his
career
young to have that it's great when you
work with people who is so thankful and
appreciative which is the same thing is
thankful and you know II mean and just
as a boat yeah so yeah yeah yeah it was
fun
I like being a regular much more it was
very exciting and better money better
money I'm very exciting to that you know
some write of some camp some us urgently
seriously interested
well yeah I'm touching you know mine
okay I'm touching you right now they
can't tell oh my man but it's like I'm
not close to touch I don't mind you got
that voice how you doing
you know I had this voice when I was a
kid I used to know my own like what
oh just measurement you got that at that
radio boys like you
this is oh is it your Uncle Joe Benson
oh give you my 405 it if you or anyone
in your family suffers from faulty
transvaginal mesh then please stop
talking about it because it's disgusting
and we don't understand what you're
talking about here yo yo how did you
want when you were in high school how
did you come up with like hey man my mom
I host my own radio show what I didn't
do that good oh you think how come I
didn't do that or you know oh I'm sorry
you look at my [ __ ] sight yeah man I
had a college radio show go to get right
now you have a watch two together New
Paltz upstate New York
did you sell stuff or like like you got
the radio voice like me voiceover for
the little hookers out here right now
you know Louie show ya FX I do that
voice like coming up next on Louie
the following program is rated tv-ma
awesome will that be good
it doesn't make great but it pays good I
can't complain the show saved my ass you
know and Louie now knows my name which
is very exciting
Ryan's galore oh hey hey but you guys
have this voice as a kid so I call my
friends to hang out and the parents will
be concerned who is this it's Brian
what do you want with what are we
looking for Bobby can you put Bobby on
the phone send out your son I want to
play with your son before the park tell
him to bring his balls
does he have extra balls of bring
you saw the great catcher by the way the
drunk could be an actor first or just
someone be a [ __ ] comedian that's a
good question I always want to be an
actor more that when I grew up I was
watching Marx Brothers Laurel and Hardy
and have a good stuff thing I want to do
Duck Soup said I want to do that really
badly
Tim Conway I used to kill me as a kid
Joe watched him come in the crowd but
that show it's to kill me when they did
that slow walking yeah and Bugs Bunny I
still ever I really want I met Bugs
Bunny other day he's very nice yeah I
really want some doctor you know he's
very right over there no blank and on
his tombstone it says that's all folks
isn't it if that's all folks
yeah and the best gravestone I've ever
seen is Jack Lemmon it just says Jack
Lemmon in and then his wrong not kind of
funny
my didn't say what's up fool fool yeah
but I see the Chavez Memorial and
Riverside you know a little plaque I
donate it for the plaque that's nice and
they want me to put what's up fool
because I thought it was offensive well
they probably kiss there's real fools
out there you know I mean but like look
I think it was offensive like this and
two stupid people would be offended by
it
yeah what's up fools if they're not man
that's not too harsh the first time you
call me fool who's talking about and
then you called everybody in I was again
right on your figure so now some people
don't get it up for it whether idiots
they fool when you're clearly joking
yeah man oh it's an endearment yeah
sorry no I know what to talk about I was
gonna say when Rodrigo does it it sounds
different
[ __ ] you how do you like Rodrigo I he's
the sweetest guy no he is do you guys
all work together
oh we just work together we're together
oops all those stories about the guy
going sign right on the door that is
funny that they thought like all you
know white guys were the same yeah you
were so I used to work in Coney Island
on a haunted house right and the Puerto
Rican would call me Weinberg you're
Weinberg that's hilarious
yeah so racist but yet
call me Weinberg why I'm worried
I think a lot of fat stuff or a
Schnauzer schnauzer so what's up fool
man hey when you start doing stand-up
may 1995 in New York City I just like
what the radio show has to do with that
in 1992 I did a show opening for a
hypnotist in my college and I tanked it
was awful you know I was so bad I just
walked off stage of the five minutes and
I was like I'm gonna come back and so
after like three days of mourning I just
like I'm gonna get a radio show that he
got a right TV show at the college and
then I did and then I didn't pay for
anything in town ever again and then I
started doing stand-up in the city so
you should play the Wolfman Jack story
what's one is that that that deejay what
man Jack did he have clear throat cancer
I don't know what he had man was he
really a Wolfman I think so man he
really was the Wolfman Wolfman Jack what
time they interview that [ __ ]
around and the answer memo what did you
come up with a Wolfman Jack till one day
I was walking in the forest his old lady
came out to me said you're gonna be the
Wolfman what that's weird
yeah I think you just copying something
from the movies you know it's for
interesting about the Wolfman you ever
see the Wolfman he doesn't eat people
here's Chuck some he's got claws and
teeth but he just runs up to people and
just chokes him that's the old 1951
Wolfman ran 19 runs tablet that's well
hit here like a smooth hair back oh yeah
a greaser yeah yeah in further get a
1950 let those scary the Wolfman doing
that that [ __ ] scary like Michael
Landon I was a teenage werewolf right
but then you go to American world for
London now we're talking a [ __ ]
werewolf that's a great movie it is good
night dude I saw this one it's called
wolf Matt wolf cop we'll stop I'll
[ __ ] Netflix oh my [ __ ] god you're
the best that was probably the worst for
the worst formation of a man turning
into a [ __ ] a werewolf like they
showed his penis explode right turn into
a wolf penis they showed us penis
explode and truth it you know what now
you're turning into the the wolf man
yeah why and you your your body ripping
you tuned into a wolf when they showed
his regular size Peters rip and turned
it to a wolf Peter sees and he's going
Yahoo Yahoo Yahoo that's awful what you
got going on man lately I just did Conan
two months ago a bad [ __ ] man
I'm around what the secret I'm like a
lot of comments trying to get on I'm
unsinkable
I mean I'm never gonna succeed but I'm
unsinkable but you get to show that like
Molly Brown Molly Brown you know thick
of all mighty Brown you don't talk about
yeah yeah you're like a sponge ball yeah
just soak it all in I won't go down I'll
get kicked I'll say I haven't the money
today I wipe my ass with coffee filters
and all I was thinking was I used to be
on TV now I wasn't never on TV you're
right
now right but now I did wipe my ass of
coffee focus don't be like that
I don't know before we don't have no
money no you got the Loess animation
money yeah well you know throwing a drug
habit changes that never laugh at you
chase coming in every week having every
three weeks yeah thanks guy did the
right the only way I did a ladder
factory is Dahmer Arrowhead it was
Tuesday show yeah and you get $20 but
but but then but but then I didn't I
don't yeah I don't go there so I I try
to get my check the next time Dom add me
back which is six months later and if
it's more than six months then I put the
chair set it on fire I got there one
time man to pick up my check and a new
attempt they're gonna send him down and
they were barely cutting them yeah yeah
I know
please I've been there I've been there
and and I'm you know I used to get
grabbed my check and I used to see like
Shawn Wayans you know Damon Wayans
hardly we're little and they don't touch
that check so it's like this is like a
shitload of check for these guys yeah
and I'll take a man oh one day I could I
could never be like that every [ __ ]
check for this place yeah yeah I
realized when I go to the Comedy Store
iliza shlesinger has all these big
checks he's huge tax just sitting there
so I'm thinking the fight when i form a
corporation I'm just in the cauterizer
/x got a good idea that's a good idea
baby this store - yeah the store the
improvin the Laugh Factory right you got
them all
I'm around I'm around I've been around
just uh you know it's interesting but I
have a new album out and I just started
this podcast I'm all things comedy
alongside you and that's why I came on
here - what the goddness it's called
this is my podcast if you go the
author's comedy site it's a picture of
me and slash pizza or I'm on iTunes
under this is my podcast Brian Lara this
is my podcast and it's very different
than what you guys doing whatever
alrighty so let's get sketches and a lot
of him improvin this all like I have a
monkey who lives next door and he knocks
on my door and he comes and yells at me
and i have arguments with the monkey
then he leaves it's pretty funny I think
Rob Brack your college ready to show car
bro back to life and I used to have all
these fans yeah and the neighboring high
schools in college whether you lose them
already show and now there's two
listenings of the show and they make
requests and I throw an old character
character old character that you did
back there yeah we had a guy who just
called his name was Feliz Navidad he was
this guy who always wanted sandwiches
used to call up people looking for
sandwiches we had the outsiders real
fortune and that was kind of fun like
I'll take a G please you've already
guessed the G no I'm sorry G please yes
well there's no more G's and then like
you spin the wheel
I love the count for $200 and for $200
I'll take the couch oh and how about the
couch for $200
well that leaves you with $200 okay I'll
take the caps know a lot of stuff you're
a federal doctor the dr. Demento
I I didn't hear him till college
somebody gave me a tape of his but did
you like that so yeah my parents long
parodies song parodies on Perry's an
award on Yankovic came on the scene that
was very exciting
yeah I admit Cosby has been you know
George Carlin's bit I go through it to
my two favorite comics what means you
want to start denim um who was the comic
that um you know I guess I'm a lot of
people but my first comedy album I
listened to with Bill car
speak which one fight my brother Russell
which I sleep with yeah yeah I heard of
the one night and I [ __ ] memorized
that she's going change the route to my
brother
Raoul who I hate yeah you know and I
memorized it and then I heard Richard
present a crazy yeah on then Eddie
Murphy delirious okay on the way home
and I think yeah man it's something here
and I memorized them let's go awesome
yeah delirious was it going yeah mine
was Bill Cosby why is there air and
George Carlin playing with your head
those and himself when himself came out
on HBO and playing with your head was
right after it to the George Carlin
special it was those I think those were
but the Billy Martin now the Steve
Martin yes a billy mom was a Billy
Martin now burst his Bridget Jackson 19
thought he was great I was Martin album
and that father didn't get it man
but if you buy it that's why I don't
like why it was $2.00 and it was at the
Sears Outlet good job you didn't get it
the one I'm a water crazy guy the one
weeds out son the one that has like an
arrow arrow yeah the one with him yeah
you didn't get it
well cuz you know I didn't get Python
when I was younger I still don't get I
don't want to get it man you don't want
to get money Python dude you're so silly
you know and it's like it's right up
your alley
because you're so silly you're very
funny right that we think fred money
Python I like Monty path
it's not a white thing man so I know why
think don't go there I'm just saying
it's very silly my manager is white and
he hates Monty Python he goes I don't
understand whatever why she hated Python
yeah but she has similar interests
hi I like Cheech and Chong in high
school that stuff yeah yeah she's sorry
it's not my second city second city the
my manager doesn't know stamp I thought
he'd understand why they're stupid
because what's the run what's the reason
for that character being stupid I think
that's what's funny about it it's just
somebody is our money Python kind of
like Princess Bride
Princess Bride is more acceptable I
guess forever but when you think it was
a long time but it but the game for
Monty Python's Ian Prince is bright now
they got Peter Cook time at the marriage
got a wedding yeah
that's Peter Cook from Peter Cook and
Dudley Moore
they were in Beyond the Fringe which was
the inspiration for Monty Python also
the gun show was it if somebody would
start somebody like some of my listeners
out there who never heard of [ __ ]
money Python in their [ __ ] life but
thinking what the [ __ ] the Python bro
oh yeah do what did he start off with
the Holy Grail or I say hurry they get a
couple of dabs and watch the Holy Grail
America is bigger in the whole America
likes what I grab and then when you get
to another level where you appreciate
the rumor you want I like the TV show in
the album's more than the movie yeah
life in the album the the TV show looks
right TV show life at Brian is big in
England the TV show is fantastic you get
out you get yourself the movie and now
for something completely different which
is the best of of the TV show just
reenacted get stoned and watch it now
for something completely different
that's a good introduction to money pot
yeah the sketch is that yeah yeah you
could just stop it every half hour you
don't gonna watch the time I'm telling
you it's [ __ ] funny there's a scale
where guys trying to teach people to
defend himself with his hey fight back
against the guy armed with a banana oh
no II just you disarmed him and then you
eat the banana you know you take it
didn't eat the banana any guys I come on
can't we learn how to defend against
people with sticks and guns
no because attack me with the strawberry
he just gives me damn doubt that's so
funny yeah what's up my almighty Python
man Monte Carlo you know maybe if
there's a physicist I'm saying something
stupid but people like Karate Python
Woody Allen if they were trying to make
it today they wouldn't but they were
original back there so maybe it's not
hysterical to people now but it it you
know I'll blaze I saw the Holy Grail at
the arch stone and there was a nice cute
little as an usher girl and she was like
I don't get it just it's just stupid and
I was like you stupid if it's a joke
where one of them goes hi I forgot to
say my hi I'm bounder of adventure I'm
smoke
too much you've got to cut down a little
bit because I'm not sorry excuse me you
better cut down because I get you people
make fun of your name all the time
because no never noticed it before his
name smoke too much and then it then on
the skid the guy just keeps talking and
he won't stop right so the host kid just
just goes what the hell stop talking to
say they literally carry him out of the
room he's still talking and then like
you just cease running around the
building still talking it's very funny
missing I just won't stop talking and
they can they can't get like shut up
shut up the whole set the one Withers
this is being hit on the head lessons
the argument that's the arc of the
argument yeah this one with his this is
being hit on there you know he wants to
complain because I mean no this is I'll
do it again I'll I never felt so Mexican
in my life yeah I heard gotta get to
this man
Lisa no all right the Mexicans I have
the American Valley let's show it
doesn't know we all know man well
depends man
so the Leary is for you and Richard
Pryor Brian Russell Russell yeah he's
going what I used to watch sketch comedy
the kid but the relays shardana
see that might get mine while the show -
out out out - ah you ever see the
footage from Woodstock with Shannon uh
appeared at Woodstock and the crowd
rioted when I Friday when I would later
on when I found out about Woodstock and
all that and I saw and I was older
kiddin man why is China and I would
stock yeah with everybody thinking the
same thing yeah they're afraid you
thinking that thing during would started
no I was no I think good of Woodstock
but I didn't I didn't really well ground
it through yeah I was too young I didn't
think it through that why was China not
Woodstock Jim Builder do boo do not
sweetheart where I heard my friend Heath
hide a good guy does cruises that Bowser
those cruises and he's like 65 and he
makes the muscle yeah yeah I think yeah
yeah he was talking he was telling the
CDs for a while I saw him when I think
he was doing a commercial one time he
came out in their flabby ass
Coco ganar we often
we forbad leave to hell in a tight ass
tank top he opens for you and yet I
black hair and he look at the dice man
kind of yeah they did he's got Cena me
he opened his mouth to do the the Balder
thing and the dentures came off nobody
that's not true
I didn't come off but I should love soon
enough they were in Greece baby they
were in Greece yeah you like sha na na I
like that about you you know cuz know
the kid like she like I would watch talk
to my dad like you know so we will come
home late at night from a party and my
dad will make us watch hee haw yeah and
my dad did not understand what the
[ __ ] say but he likes white titties so
a tight white booties interesting so
we're watching hee haw but I understand
the jokes especially when they come out
of the hey do a little stupid one-liner
you know even for as a white person I
never watched he huh and I think that
makes you more white than us [ __ ] lo
hee hope my dad loved hee haw if I will
tell you the type of movie that my
father likes you'll be like with Chuck
my favorite movie is overboard with Kurt
Russell that bad movie my dad loves that
movie good morning Goldie Hawn why
because he's a carpenter that's what
that loved that movie he loves vacation
come over my death free receipt on
vacation and he's driving and he sees um
them supermodel that Carly Jones next
wife and I don't love that part but yeah
it's a it's a good scene you then like
so just my dad just like being the road
Theater by himself and white shakes or
just being lonely yeah interesting
so what was it was your mother around or
did he do the wrong interesting cleany
buddy no so my mother never liked
vacation because she always hated the
fact that Chevy Chase was looking at
another woman when she was married when
he was married you know I mean yeah we
didn't like that same way my mom didn't
like that party the button notice he
totally my dad would laugh I didn't
notice he'll make me look look at the
set she said look at the white any no a
littler he really go he's so fun flirty
he's flirting he's funny and then it
overboard but he was watching huh and
then overboard who wants overboard in my
that friends will be there my del
translate what happened no no I let me
look he's gonna [ __ ] convince her to
clean everything I record to everything
you know he just don't think it to us I
want everything that my mom does already
right but she did get bucked and I hate
to do it so what's up man bye that's
funny you're on a show now you work in
the show no ah I have the podcasts and
just have an album out on iTunes go
Brian scelera live at the comedy castle
and Brian scleral sneezes farts and
orgasms so do you encourage Michael
Kremer to do comedy again and she's so
interesting what you have did you guys
listen to another pocket I got it you
don't mean your dog the interesting I'm
here with weapons bro very interesting
store the part can you just go oh you
could a Rambo for about an hour
the well in 2005 we had the guy here
that convinced Kramer to go apologize
after it happened Oh Oh Julian
McCullough with here but Julian
McCullough told me Gopal Chile was there
that night yeah yeah I forgot Sully was
there that night I think there that
night are you sure he would have figured
out to apologize anyway well this is the
story 2005
I'm flying from New York to LA on
JetBlue
I mean the brag but that's what that's
what was happening give Luther [ __ ] back
then it was the shake I was for aisle
and then this couple cook this car comes
in I was on the aisle stretched out like
a soldier now I sit in the window cuz
I'm not talking anyway so this couple
comes in the guy sits in the middle the
girl sits on the window not on the
window
she didn't said we would have crashed
she sat in the chair by the window got
it we're flying to LA this is right
before our books that okay Madison so I
was like I'm gonna get a pilot I'm gonna
get a show I sweat was the year for me
and we're flying then I realize the guy
stood next to me as Michael Richards so
I'm like all right I just leave him
alone cuz Yeti I mean you know he's I'm
guessing you want to be left alone
six-hour flight so we start eventually
the Seri Lanka floods going on TV and he
points through and he goes in that
horrible and I'm like yeah we just
talked about it for a while at him we
know so you have mutual friends and he
was very nice he was extremely nice and
so then he was like what do you do
like I tried I act and you know and I'm
a comedian because I can never do that
how's a guy you should do it you should
do it I was like I saw you host a young
comedian special a long time it goes
yeah but I didn't really just and I was
like yeah but it's like you know if you
looking for something to do why not do
that and there's a club called the Laugh
Factory you go down there you tell them
that you want your name not on the list
so you could practice with a big crowd
it was a go came so cut to a month later
I got the part I'm flying back and on
the same TV on the JetBlue comes up
Michael Richards explodes on laughs
actor stage and I'm just like you got to
be kidding me and I got the TV show so I
always considered meeting him to be like
a sign that things were gonna go well
and it's so one flight my career started
in the history ended in one flight an
interesting but he couldn't have been
any more nice to me and I do want to say
that and from what and I'm sure you know
I worked with him that I think he just
got flustered because you know crowd
work is difficult and I think that from
what I know about him whenever he felt
cornered he would say something really
awful to like draw attention away from
the thing that it was really going on so
I think that was just his reflex and it
just happened to be a racist one but I
don't think I don't have from what I can
see I don't know him well enough but I'm
sure there was no race as a minimum I
thought it was just crowd work gone very
bad because he panicked cuz that's a
skill that you had to develop over years
and I considered the whole thing my
fault yeah yeah you do
he's a very nice guy I think it was my
fault yeah Fred agrees and Fred works
with him yeah yeah he agrees you know
it's people Jimmy Kimmel said it's not a
racist he's crazy he just uh almost
seemed like he was trying to do Andy
Kaufman performance art yeah you know
they mean not he just yeah there's
afraid then the very next line he says
that's that that's that horrible
language we're all used to hearing right
like he wanted we start right to be I
was trying to start a bit that he didn't
have written yeah you know and it just
happened to be really bad timing
yeah I I don't know things could really
ruin a career unless you murder someone
because people love
celebrities and he tried another show it
didn't go I would Kirstie Alley yeah
that's show they just cast them things
wrong III he's laid low for a while yeah
they didn't need that I had lunch with
Paul Rubin pee-wee Herman many years ago
and that's how bad you he sort of self
exiled himself even before he had that
masturbation arrest so I think you know
I mean I think even when when that
happened with Michael Richards I thought
he's got nothing better to do it and do
the Laugh Factory so that was sort of
his choice in a way yeah I never go away
cuz he could have done like monk and you
know ya know kind of practice be moving
home you can go there and practice I
just say I think guys want that creative
outlet and attention and that's when
he's just bad timing when these iPhones
I just came out now we'll never see a
phone come out I don't [ __ ] say [ __ ]
I just caught you taping me that's
interesting has anybody work here and I
usually you know when you said that I
hate that yeah it's awful you know um I
did a show last Monday I did a show with
Josh Adam Meyers I don't know if you
know him I think it's a good show it's
called uh the goddamn Comedy Jam and
they have comedians do it eight minutes
set and they have a live band and you
get to play that your favor rock song
with the band
mmm after your set and notify comedians
and the piano guy would appear from the
Comedy Store uh-huh
Oh Jeff Jeff yeah Jeff will play piano
so I got to do um light my fire okay you
know that it would be untrue you know
that I would be yeah so I did that and
so I'm glad that you know that I don't
do so many shows here in our lay that
people don't people don't like oh they
don't get excited you Phillipe Esparza
yeah I'm gonna do a headline people
[ __ ] bring out to the phones so long
story short Hannibal Buress you know he
went up on stage mmm all the phone's
came out my other sudden I didn't just
took Twitter
the whole vibe you know note the whole
great new of the show they were
yeah nobody was taking their cell phones
- he got on right now everybody's taping
his whole act he mentions that so he did
what what I would have done he went back
to it then his old material again so he
couldn't work no more but he was killing
it so I get annoyed by it I know that
Russell Peters he has security guards
now interesting so that so that's what
that's good advice so when somebody
starts taping you do your own stuff yeah
I just go to my old stuff so yelling at
them and saying the end where it doesn't
work now do they work specially there
late if the maximum doesn't work it
doesn't work at all man they get pissed
off like like I know that Russell peter
has his security with the little laser
beams hmm and they pointed the crowd a
turn their phone off now although they
make them delete everything yeah
interesting
make him delete everything yeah like
stand there go ahead they need a strong
armament alidium I'm gonna be like a
Mexican cartel no just walk into a to a
club have my goons pass our bags take
care of myself on the way
enjoy the show at the end of the show
I'm gonna do I'm gonna back Jeff see
what to call them the movie with 57 yes
it is 11 yeah when they have the thing
called the pinch and they just said it I
don't know the electronic stuff times
just after your set just press the
button go back and erase everybody's
[ __ ] phones it's a reasonable idea
guys I don't know why you do that yes I
would love to have that oh but you have
to steal it you ever see Ocean's eleven
yeah you did
okay when did you know one although no
psycho mom
all right yeah that's - video wonder
they have phones haha that's true yeah
there was no pension at first do people
do that allow your shows that are
recording you sometimes yeah
what do you do you get pissed off I
don't get pissed off anymore ever since
the mega-rich thing I don't get pissed
off anymore on stage I just I just kind
of like make reference to it and look
for help in the room and if nobody helps
me I just I kind of just like deal with
the guy and if I have recently in San
Diego just had to give up nobody was
helping me and has had to keep doing
jokes cuz I had nothing I could do just
got would not stop recording what wasn't
supposed to walk offstage and piss off
and repeat man I saw dude I saw a woman
at what my show
she was sitting in the third floor no
third leg third row all right man I saw
her fix her
I started getting her big old shot her
Big O here being up improv class okay
stack them right next to each other
right and then I'm put her phone
perfectly honest she so she could record
me while she was sat there what to show
what the [ __ ] and I wanted to tell her
what the [ __ ] you're doing you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you really paid $20 I've given you
a comedy show you know that people are
serving your food nothing to steal the
show and put on Instagram for what so
you get 30 likes who the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] because they're 30 likes so what
happened no I just I'm not crying I
leave I go there I said you want to
record something and I put my dick out
man
and I didn't I wanted to you got to get
so long yeah my don't know what to do
man but I know that it bothers a lot of
other comments like Dave Chappelle he
came to work on new material anywhere
yeah yeah yeah I'm showing us so he
can't by the time I assume he's doing
this stuff everybody's pulling iPhones
up we just have to invent the games just
changing completely I don't know what's
gonna happen to our job
everything's gone like what no reality
shows a scripted so now the actors are
gone so what what been exchanging
oddities sure right we have to do
stand-up in our living room
Oh like on camera broadcaster working
Alzheimer's patients right let the
stand-up comedian she do her one hour
right in front of her mom and dad in her
living room
and she's great now right yeah Oh Maria
Bamford worried about for now she really
record releases yes yeah one hour
special and then that's it am I gonna do
something different I'm gonna just you
know waiting for people to tell you
company sure sure though if she nobody
would I went up to her Maria Bamford as
I didn't know how I got an idea for you
Maria yeah I talked to all these agents
yeah we got a booth at a million dollars
we're gonna pull for this you in your
house mom and dad watching you leave the
room that's gonna be one of the it's
gonna be great it's a great idea jealous
oh that's a good idea
I'm thinking you know of doing this
anybody want to think about good at
whatever special having everybody just
come in and record the whole hour
special on their phone
you get really see yourselves you guys
do the marketing for me right you put it
out there make sure you here's the
background just take it out y'all think
we should give that idea and grow and
find an accountant and pay you so you
can rely on them if they seem like safe
people trusted trustworthy people just
take it out there people you're our
special there'll be a horrible special
being every different angles so everyone
with your hair fatty weight would use
white yeah what was just bulge
I hate when the record room an
especially with a mother Laugh Factory
on [ __ ] Thanksgiving and I'm bombing
yeah that's when the cameras come out
all they come on I want you to mom and
then I'm out there you know and I'm
telling the audience okay I'll put a
little recording make sure you write
down their today's Christmas and I'm
performing in front of homeless people
right it's good
homeless people have the cameras filming
oh yeah how most people have cameras
it's interesting
they got laptops they're like Nina
Starbucks all day I said homeless guy
asked me for money and I was like I know
how many money he's my card now and he
had a little machine for me to wipe [ __ ]
[ __ ] no hit a paper countdown he pulled
his penis and that's Felipe's act and he
start over coordinate you know the funny
man you have a you play that homeless
gang cartoons
excuse me you play that a homeless gang
card your homeless guy and laugh until I
have made a lot of yet I played a
homeless I did play a homeless guy in
life and in the weird voice unlike a
homeless guy for TV it was perfect I
said to that I said Steve do you want me
to change my voice just now that's
perfect
well it was very I heard I have video of
me of as a kid I literally sound like
one of the kids from Jaws one like hey
dad we want to go on the water like the
pond is for ladies dad give us a
Brooklyn accent I think I'm doing it I
think this is it but we all have broke
we all have a version of Brooklyn
accents the three of us yo
just little neighborhoods some fool
what's so fool you know I may be such
self-hatred cuz when I talk to some
friends said of the accident when I hear
how I talk it and annoys me
I saw it yeah I'm the same way you get
annoyed when you hear stuff that sounds
like you yeah well after people point it
out like but it's amazing how wouldn't
you leave and you be here for 14 years
how people will still pick pick it out
you know and I hate the sounds like I'm
named Robin maybe I am but when I did
madmen I got hired because of my voice
the guy liked he's like I want you to
been hiding it for 14 years I wanted out
and I was like I don't know if I can use
and I want you to be more New York
that's why I'm giving you the part I'm
like alright so I all right
but the more I try the more cartoonish
this [ __ ] sounds and on saying okay
whenever read for dumb Italians it
bothers the [ __ ] out of me you know like
it with Joey MOOC will come up we just
want to get some [ __ ] lasagna come on
come out with the batter with you I
don't like reading that [ __ ] do you
don't like you when did you like you had
a little Mexican red more marinara sauce
to that please you a little more
boldness did you get that instead yes
the other book I read for a Italian
comic it was all but big mobile Italian
jokes it was all right in like the
minute I get there I don't light I've
done it where I've had you please tell
him mobster to write
oh yeah I've had a few jobs where I get
hard one animate one voiceover thinking
we like what you did but don't do the
New York accent they thought it's like I
made a choice yeah I'm an animation
guiding it's a good character but tell
not to do the New York accent I went to
this commercial and they keep telling me
they're going over it like correcting me
to not sound too new Yorkish right well
why'd you hire me it's like like they
hired Schwarzenegger or Pele you know
and they keep they have the consultant
telling him how to say words like they
kept coming up to me don't say so I say
yeah
yeah it's like when I read for focus
that's what that movie focused right I
read for the part of the his psyche the
guy the guy who God actually looks just
like me but uglier
yes curly hair beard same thing chubby
just shorter what what's focus again I
don't know somewhere bombed with Will
Smith oh yes yes I remember that yeah
and remember the lead when I read it
could they get a call back
oh yeah that's think that's the guy from
he was in mint have Ben Stiller movie
where he travels the country yeah you
know the daydreaming guy yeah you Walter
Mitty didn't Walter Mitty that guy yeah
and you'd better look at them anything
that movie Castle mu poverty and the
cowboy there's no reason to curse yeah
there and and then I was like I goes up
well do not looking for a guy from
easterly you know that's the first time
that lady well maybe he traveled yeah
maybe he's a World Travel guy from
easterly who got well connected with his
mobsters because a bad [ __ ] man
is that guy Mexican that guy no he's um
Peruvian something South America he look
like something that could play
everything yeah exactly that's what they
want yeah
so you just give them a color so it
shuts him up yeah so when I read man the
way they are they don't want this they
want this guy to be on Armenian or
something right or Lebanese they want
you to be Armenian my friend but if I
water okay I could see in there my
friend
yeah we have to change the t-shirt but
yeah and further I went to was I went to
when we were in Miami daughter play
scholar Dom they could they fix broken
phones and I thought it was like a
Middle Eastern place because it was
caught it was caught I break no it was
caught you break I fix
really yeah they break these eight they
Facebook your phone's breaking laptop
told you but I got fix you break a fix
and I'm hoping it go ahead and see this
big Arab guy you know you break I fix do
you mind waiting for like Mexican parts
are they so are they so like Mexican
sometimes it abolish you know most of
the parts
read that I feel is more Mexican I read
it because I know that I'm not gonna get
it anyways right they might get okay
a guy who from Peru who sells it better
right yeah I guess most most of the
Mexican were like it they give it to non
Mexican guys but I really Sally better
or or they do more Mexican it stuff than
you and you're something cuz you have
more than Mexican going on for you yeah
and I bet you sometimes it's like with
me with the Italian when they get called
in for a time like well that guy's
Italian but funny and we don't really
want that we want Italian
and you when you go in you seem to be
Mexican to yourself to Mexican guy like
him but I wish he was just five inches
shorter right I have it where I had an
audition where they want character II
but regular guy character II because it
because I'm right away you notice
something off they did I audition for a
little part and uh man no sex no art you
brought your clothes no yeah but they
had these weird guy but they were
regular guy weird you know kind of
balding and he seems like a regular guy
than he's a loft right away like this
guy's shouldn't be anywhere you know
yeah your distinctive you're not just
Italian that's good like like I know I'm
wasting my time if I auditioned for like
method it's a ran law and order as the
Irish butcher no I could be a butcher
but they're gonna wait a minute that's
awfully funny time we want a guy who
looks like a stereotypical yes
stereotypical all [ __ ] out of me first
yeah whenever I read from Law & Order I
always read for the fat guy who may or
may not be [ __ ] that made a girl
uncomfortable yeah they weren't you
might go for the part but they weren't a
guy who I she looks like Bob's Burgers
yeah when I read for fat guys I never
get it cuz there's always a 400-pound
guy in the room you know and I'm if
they're gonna give it the hip but yeah
that's that bothers us or mucus what
you're the guy yeah alright if I go to a
Greek guy now but but yeah if you're
distinctive and unique like you to yeah
you're not just like you as a Mexican
guy your which is great your Felipe as
far than me either they want me or not
right when I audition if they know me
I'm not gonna get it but they gotta want
me I'm a dumber man you're great okay
thank you
I pretty much know your whole resume
no not much when I get there like fresh
souls gonna be a cause like what why
isn't it yes the mix of Seth and I'll be
the coast let me be the guest maybe
we'll have him back
okay [ __ ] I'm back you've done very well
yeah first I know you gotta go soon
right next week on Louie how do you do
that
coming up on coming up next on Louie
Louie you know I got the part because
they wanted New York voices so I played
a Korean store owner and I play a Jewish
old lady and they gave her the part and
then effect said well they just want a
regular voice I originally did it like a
subway announcer next stop Louie
stand clear closing doors you know Louie
FX tonight 10:30 stand clear close the
doors so I got that by doing that and
did an old Jewish lady and then there
now they just want coming up next
how would you another Mexican soap opera
I have to be honest with you I don't
watch them cuz I don't know the [ __ ] the
same just coming up on no chose Nino's
never baby a lot of TV shows you just
watch for the tits but unlike your dad
now we have the internet so I don't
really watch shows for good-looking
people anymore they're like there's a
good-looking guy and there's a
good-looking girl in this movie she goes
say it dude the internet exists now I
can just jerk off give me a nice [ __ ]
give me flip a sponsor yeah my death
little ball hee-haw and by any good they
got a when they make the hee-haw movie
your father's gonna be first on one he'd
be the first guy that my I just you know
be affluent he is always overalls ready
whenever I have a voiceover I have a
voiceover additions where I know I'm not
going to get cuz Bank of America just a
Jewish or they have three different
parts and I got just do one thing yeah
yeah you know I'm very lazy I booked two
commercials last year which is my Honda
in Spanish Honda in Spanish totalmente
Honda Fit oh wait but at these both use
voiceover and yeah character they got
wrote it for me oh that's bull okay that
makes sense yeah and then I did I got a
target mobile
do the deep thing again I've never seen
you that focused ever it is the
tournament the Honda Fit own win fit but
I'm really impressed filet but you can
train it in the all new Honda Fit it's
all just a fake good
for you okay he ran into some prejudiced
at the hotel because they have this
continental like kiosk with free
breakfasts but it's only for this like
teachers if you're part of a teaching
group so I'm there scooping cereal they
go you can't do it no way no way he's a
teacher the oil teachers thought it was
on black he's gonna walk he was a little
man of a mani fanny mag he's not there
sit eating like idiot I'm open front of
the lady right like where can we get it
where's more coffee at then I asked her
one quick question on that footage if
for the guests and I almost don't know
oh that would be a dick and it would be
like write me I'm gonna go but this
guy's not even [ __ ] either maybe
eating off for free all week I don't
want to be that guy no more yeah yeah
you just order none I don't want to eat
here man anyways right actually cool you
know yeah yeah
like the problems I want to just go off
like I did with that [ __ ] [ __ ]
from the Sheraton inverter oh [ __ ] you
dollar you know what you know who you
are yeah you know what I like doing
I like showing up of course in a big
[ __ ] problem when they don't let have
smoking rooms I like to make sure that I
put on my worst pajama bottoms possible
a t-shirt that doesn't fit so my ass
crack hangs out and then I like walking
through the lobby holding a pack of
cigarettes tradition packing it and just
just I'm just gonna stand out at our
front smoke a cigarette walk bye-bye
everybody
just hurt their business as much as
possible get a [ __ ] smoking room get
one room give one room of smoking them
[ __ ] you you know if the windows open do
you smoke
what if the windows open the hotel would
use [ __ ] is I'm not smoking or smoking
I don't smoke in a master only I don't
do that don't break the law
I want other people's stuff if it's my
car if it's a rent-a-car and they say no
cigarettes
[ __ ] you I'm smoking I rented this car
if it's room I'm not gonna do that I'm
not gonna have them at $300 on my credit
card
you know I mean I can keep the air going
in a rental car I can't keep the air
going on not smoke me if I don't care
about the hotel room and they already
pissed me off
I spoke anyways and in a firm popcorn
but do it but do they do that's very
funny but do they charge your credit
card now man is
charming for burnt popcorn tonight I did
the well it's called the Bates what a
brilliant idea what would they call
fakes again or dabs dabs when I did the
dabs oh I was so blitzed in my room but
I was still trying to hold back opening
the five-dollar M&Ms
I was hungry but I said Fred try to
sleep if you can't sleep in a half-hour
and I'd walk by I still had to
discipline not to want to spend five
bucks for the M&Ms it was tempting and
and and you kept getting free water from
the club so we don't have to take the
water from the hotel we could packing it
in that's nice yeah I steal everything
they thought that I was not the reason
that's not for you the buffet right
right they were at the comedy club he
goes to the bar after a drink a day at
the bar so that's the first dollar and
tells them sir don't touch it to drink
man until they cut you a to drink
million of it you a man performing
tonight he was relieved like because I
could tell you to drink the cranberry
juice but it's not going taught you to
drink minimum
I have a veil right you know oh it's so
Mickey Mouse these clubs like I can't
like when I'm at the ice house I is my
truth coupons because I gave you them
like I and my age I'm trying to con you
for drink coupons like skee-ball I told
you for breakfast every morning man you
know and then ya know the woman says she
did you you did so good this week I'm
not taking the money out for your hotel
for your for extra night you know what I
do whenever I steal toilet paper from
everywhere I'm gonna steal something
here I steal things from hotel rooms the
toilet paper for motel rooms when I
shoot on a lot and I have a little
trailer I steal the toilet paper I steal
it
what do you Madonna man I was gonna I
was gonna [ __ ] him for that I'm gonna
book him anything I'm producing but now
I'm not we don't have the budget for
toilet paper
oh yeah give coffee filters you want to
announce that your comedy dates uh oh I
don't have a memorize but when is this
gonna air it's gonna hear death Friday
it's gonna air this Friday yeah this
Friday and Saturday I am in Scottsdale
at the comedy spot
next week I can really use a lot of
people at this my first time had money
in the Cleveland improv very resolution
Thank You first time headling I'm very
very excited you stay at the condo
saying either come okay there's a guy
there at the condo he's in the condo
yeah that's Kenny ask any guy he lives
in the condo yeah with me but be a guide
know that the guy stay in the condo my
time interview you all right if yeah if
anybody hits you off or emails you to do
a site interview I'll do I would take
that interview because that guy gets
good stuff okay I'm sorry to replace
your question with don't I get back to
my but my days you will like it
three improv I've done with you they all
look the same they're all the same all
are they all the same
no improv okay now Cleveland improv is
actually right on this nice little liver
it's very pretty just on the fringes of
a mall but it you know it's a naturally
like an old still meal yeah yeah I like
that I hope I open for Tracy Morgan
there so what a surprise
that's the only improper you could get
there from Detroit on a boat
really yeah you know I'm talking about
all those three they're like like during
Islanders yeah yeah yeah yeah I got you
there's a lot of punchlines and that are
like you're performing and then you go
across the street and do your shift at
the mattress store I'm all fan of your
comedy by the way where you probably I
feel guilty interrupting us
oh I'm sorry next week Cleveland improv
the week after I'm in New York
headlining the brokerage in Long Island
Bell more no more I used to do the first
time there and then woke low then I'll
be at the Comedy Cellar stand-up New
York a comic strip easeful Broadway
comedy club Gotham comedy club a
Dangerfield's when I'm in New York and
then I come back and have a very big
show where I'm headlining the Irvine
improv first time I had Loni in the new
building there and I'm excited about I
know it's big you told hat to you but
I'm actually I'm excited to headline
that room on the south yeah man 17th of
June and then I think that's enough for
now
and then I got the two albums if you
look at me up on iTunes I can always use
some real toilet paper so please support
me and check out my podcast man I'm
putting my heart and soul into it
all these [ __ ] skits of [ __ ] might
ask for people so you know what did you
start stand-up and and there's nothing
wrong with that because we need people
like that oh yeah but nobody's doing
skits for nobody out there and I'm doing
things for free and I haven't
those bloody men yeah so I have that
going up and otherwise I want to say to
you two
one thing I was gonna say to you one of
my favorite things about playing the
Laugh Factory is that I got to always
Chum around with you and and watch you
perform and I don't get to do that
anymore since you want I miss that you
know your boys one of my favorites well
thank you man sure yeah you're a funny
guy man [ __ ] [ __ ] I've always been a
thing uh this is not a threesome body
this is how nobody nobody loved my
favorite Joe why I didn't hear that one
I'm serious he's got a lot he's oh no no
I know material interesting about
Felipe's you were influenced by guys
like Stephen right like he let ya dick
one-liners yeah you don't have to be
mess you know like Philippe yeah you
don't have to be Mexican but you have to
be Mexican to buy a ticket now I don't
in all the shows I work with you there
were only like four African Americans
yeah metal guard again guards know it's
funny when we were taking photos right
before that guy attacked you into the
green room I said I was taking a photo I
was taking for a bunch of people in a
big line then I saw the all the only
white people in the room talking to you
and I said look on Fred's fan base back
there was the last show like this like
milf with her little saw in a white
dress
yeah these disgorges woman notice her
right away when he look like um your
love she though the mother looked like
the sister of these two blond girls yeah
and and this guy look like the DES
second guy like you say the Dos Equis
man Oh with three there was a little
table white piece around it yeah they
could smother money
10b right well Matt this week people
albeit Chicago I'll show they're sold
already tomorrow
don't bother that's great man yes at
Joe's Bar think with Mikey oh you know
what so thank you Mike yo man you would
put a good show good job we did it
Austin Texas I'll be at the capital city
comedy club made
27th through the 30th all right people
June 6th a Gyptian theater Boise Idaho
first time there let's see what happens
okay man I'm coming to Bath two masters
shoots it for the first time how do you
say Massachusetts you heard me
Massachusetts that's right you got a
right I feel like a Native American
right at the way they pronounce it
anyway so I'm going there to Boston
Massachusetts then I say you got it
right you're saying it's so right that
it sounds weird all right then we see
Massachusetts you're like Massachusetts
you're really pronouncing it yeah I'd
like you're in class like June 18th
through the 20th
laughs Boston baby are you doing laughs
great the answer and first time there
San Diego June 25th through the 28th an
American comedy club and those show will
sell out before the weekend star so make
sure you get your tickets at Filippis
worldcom also going to the ice house you
probably already heard I'm coming back
I'm bringing my own drink tickets this
time it's gonna be good
Brian Scott Laura was so fool you wanna
give us a final thought yeah um I had
the worst glow you've been to really why
you want to say that one divorce condo
when we go first
worst condo man well I can if I if I
mentioned its mention the city I'll tell
you this worst condo I stayed at Chicago
I get in there
first of all there's [ __ ] in the toilet
ah [ __ ] that right
hey let me get bonus second of all
there's a woman upstairs who's got OCD
and she's vacuuming hardwood floors at 8
a.m. so then I tapped her floor with the
screwdriver and she screamed like there
was a ghost in our apartment and it made
me feel so bad and that was probably the
worst condo I've stated I think for me
any condo that has a VHS is part of the
worst condo right now some still don't
have any time there where the emcee
sleeping on the couch I've had that hell
I wanna I woke up to son you know son
and I want I you know I said I can't
sleep I'm gonna watch TV and wait a min
the guys on the couch I can't watch TV I
said you got to get him out of here you
get a yeah
or well I hate Cher
condoms with people hate it yeah made it
I don't want to be hung me every [ __ ]
asleep and I mean and I don't want to
leave the room because somebody else is
sleeping in the other room I don't like
sleeping with comics I don't know you
know I mean yeah but that's three
together you I think we should do
yeah yeah yeah bad flip is I open from
sleep I once a long time ago I bought
cocaine and you were like oh it's really
bad if I drank sprite with it and it
came out my nose I was a kid and I was
like really like no no that's right I
work for that we were a pile of Vegas
euros years ago yeah paddy Hollywood
goddamn and I started seeing that girl
yeah she was really nice yeah years ago
what 2002 the makeup artists right your
lady Ryan no that was a different one or
a hairstyle there was a different one
that you met it was I've had a lot of
girlfriends for a fat guy yeah man
so what's off red man no I think
podcasts coming up soon I'm stockpiling
one here okay for all things comedy
great so it's hard getting guest man so
I'm not like you said I know I have a
variety shows character like bright
color I don't want to talk to that
because on every comedian I'm gonna have
random people I want whoever want to do
it rather than have Louis black Louis
black hey how'd your at Carnegie Hall go
everyone's done that stuff so it's just
that and my paperbacks coming out in
September so dressed right that's about
it it's awesome I'm gonna look for your
book the guest role book yeah yeah was
so full he was a Yemen yeah man is about
a bigger they're human Jana
yeah he was a weird Rodrigo laughs ah
thank you brush the low ropes for me
gasps thanks very much